[Music]
what's going on
reject nation it's Greg Alva here a lot
of people on especially on my Facebook
and Twitter we're sending me over this
article from IGN that was a breakdown of
the trailer that they shared a d23 Expo
for Avengers infinity war and I was
thinking to myself like well I'm not
going to read this because you know
Comic Con is coming out so they're
probably going to release the trailer at
Comic Con I said that to a couple of
them and both of them said well the
trailer actually might not premiere
until November then may Mego I don't
worry about a long come on a ruin this
for myself a little bit here we are
right now and as a heads up for those
who want our Dunkirk review set in a
previous video that we might be late to
some reactions reviews that come up on
Friday at Comic Con but I was like you
know what I want to be on top of that
for the subscribers I know most of the
subscribers care more about getting up
those reactions and reviews more than
our Dunkirk reviews so we're not
watching dunker till like Tuesday now
because we wanted to go on imax because
we saw 10 minutes of footage of that
imax and we were like well there's no
other way to watch this and I want my
first time watching this to be on IMAX
and they're all sold out until Tuesday
that's going to be a little bit late but
we'll be on top of the comic-con stuff
anyway let's read this that did it here
is there's the article thank you to all
you folks who sent this over to me okay
is from IGN after opening with the
sequence that shows the Guardians
literally running into Thor amidst a
scene of cosmic carnage ooh that sounds
super exciting the guardians of it
especially good throw Ragnarok looks a
little bit like guardians of the galaxy
now there was a sizzle reel of scenes
showing the Avengers and shadows and
battle Josh Brolin Thanos who wasn't
wearing his helmet in the scenes also
seemed to have the upper hand in every
scene oh here's the actual breakdown
beware of spoiler from spider-man
homecoming ahead okay if you haven't
seen the spider-man homecoming it might
not want to read this death follows him
like a shadow
mantis says of Thanos okay yeah that's
good opening line making mantis a little
bit more important there you know it's
cool to have her be in the front or of
this footage peter has spidey sense oh
cool he's writing in a school bus as the
hairs on his arm stand up as the village
ships descend to earth
OCC man-to-man to see Mendes and then
you see Peter spy since this wreck is
John what would I saw an interview with
him recently where he was talking about
how he didn't want the spidey sense in
spider-man homecoming specifically
although I thought it was in Civil War I
thought he had a thought there was one
moment where he had it for a second but
yeah they don't really have that in
spider-man homecoming so that's really
exciting actually who he has a study
says he I remember John was talking
about having the spidey sense maybe in
future installments but he wanted to
avoid you know anything that would
remind you of the former movie
installments I came so this is really
cool Spidey has a new costume the sleek
one he rejected from Tony at the end of
homecoming we all saw that coming that
was that was one of their you know and
Cu setups they were doing Gamora walking
around the collector's layer or aether
from Thor the dark world is stored
okay okay I need to pick up on my knowns
a little bit more on that
Loki operate up the Cosmic Cube you son
of a big you son of AB a Loki a massive
ship crashing into a planet so we don't
know what planet that is seems like the
Avengers including Iron Man star-lord
and Spidey are in another realm at one
point ah I remember when they showed
that that special footage a few months
ago I think that was like maybe back in
December January where they had a big
green screen and some you know
destruction around them and it was it
was a hell of a actors names Tony Stark
Robert Downey jr. - Chris Pratt and Tom
Holland they were all standing next to
each other's stuck in another realm
already just from these first few lines
they are going all over the place you
know you got mantis Peter in New York
the Spider Man Iron Man and star-lord
and another realm the more in the
collectors lair Loki offering up the
Cosmic Cube shift crashing into a planet
that they don't have to specify here
okay
and then this does put a smile on my
face
Thanos declares as he arrives on the
planet and confronts you Badgers on
Doctor Strange and star-lord all trying
to fight him Doctor Strange and
star-lord working together it's all
trying to fight him does that mean like
all the adventures and doctor star and
dr. star lore Doctor Strange and
star-lord are trying to fight him I
think that's what it means or is it just
Doctor Strange and started working
together that was a combo I didn't
really expect to see I wasn't expecting
like it's the trailer to show us but I
like that I like the not so obvious
mashups of scenes what is this is kind
of overwhelming my imagination through
well right now quick shots of the Winter
Soldier and black panther in Wakanda
that's right there's what Conda to
Winter Soldier and black panther in
Wakanda because you know what your
soldier was in Captain America Civil War
they showed he'd be staying in Wakanda
which makes me wonder are they going to
I don't think Winter Soldier will be in
Black Panther but I imagine he might
appear in like a post-credits scene or a
mid-credits scene now that they're
saying this year cap shows up and all
cats get it with a beard that makes
sense yeah he's been a fugitive this
whole time just like Anibal Berger said
Iron Man has a new kind of Hulk Buster
type armor and possible with different
match of armor sweet because you know I
know a lot of people weren't a huge fan
of Avengers age of Ultron that was a
little bit of a disappointment for a
good amount of people a lot of people
did like it before a bunch of eight
comments are coming in but one thing we
can all are very odd was that Hulk
Buster sue is pretty freaking sweet
Thanos palming Thor's head like he's
going to pop it like a balloon mmm
that really does that one line there
really does emphasize just how powerful
fatness is if he can just pop Thor's
head like a balloon popper Tommy
oles Oh sounds violent Black Widow looks
super different different hair she's
blonde
it's going to enhance has been blonde
before I can get her brother being
blonde she's she's hot either way looks
like there are several different battles
on different fronts what more would you
want Santa's wielding the gauntlet
destroying a celestial body of some kind
it was so quick but is either a planet
or a moon and it whorls it at them from
the white whoa dang they they have not
been showing in the movies just how
powerful Thanos is holy crap crushes
this crushing Thor's head like he's
going to pop it like a balloon destroys
a celestial body of some kind it was
their platic armory hurled it at them
from the ground keys is Tony start The
Last Man Standing is his premonition
from age of Ultron coming through I that
beginning thing with Scarlet Witch his
face was action he was shaken that
sounds awesome that sounds incredible I
wish I was at d23 to actually see all
this footage I'm kind of hoping that
they don't like those two parts of me
now one part of me is like I'm hoping it
release it at Comic Con because I want
to see all this the other part of me is
I'm hoping they postpone it release
until November like how a lot of people
were telling me it will be want to be
released until then so that way I can
semi forget about some of what I've read
from here so that way it feels even more
fresh when I see the trailer right now
this all sounds amazing either [ __ ]
they're really showing they're going
over from all the movies that have come
before infinity war everything from Iron
Man to Spider Man homecoming and even
Black Panthers are coming up and Thor
Ragnarok cutting around to all those and
then show you how it's all leading up to
that O's and I love that
The Avengers movies you know they keep
hinting at that as an infinity war and
if you catch keep up with the stories
and if you're a comic book fan you you
like you're aware who Thanos is how
powerful it is but for just average
moviegoers even for someone like me who
doesn't really read the actual comics
themselves this is really exciting
because
the movies themselves haven't been
showing me just how powerful that nose
is and now we're going to actually see
it and holy moly does this sound nuts it
really does feel like the Avengers
aren't actual peril I've heard a couple
of theories of how it might actually go
down that you know most of them might
die and there's all rumors and nothing
confirmed that most of them I die then
Doctor Strange we'll have to do is you
know time loop time reversal thing and
then part two to all this I mean there's
just so much to look forward to from
looking from just reading this slide II
with his new costume the one that we saw
the iron spider suit just a description
of Iron Man star-lord and Spidey all in
another realm at one point just the
scene with the three of them interacting
sounds incredible Doctor Strange and
star-lord I love the the description of
those two lines because like these are
the sarcastic funny characters I would
have unlike that heard about Rocket
Raccoon at one point in here cap with a
beard how cool is it whenever a
character shows up with a beard it's
always badass Iron Man's you Hulk Buster
type armor black widow looking different
than theirs because that's kind of
reflect and as Tony Stark the last man
standing I don't think that'll be it
it'd be cool if it was like Tony Stark
and Doctor Strange is the last man
standing I feel like those two that are
acting would be the most exciting
because they're so similar with each
other I feel like they'd be very
competitive and I know according to this
article that these are just highlights
from the trailer this isn't a full
detailed breakdown of what the trailer
actually fully consists of but just
those little highlights are pretty sweet
I'm hoping this movie three hours long I
would gladly watch a three hour movie of
this I really have open room you best
believe that when the trailer comes down
we'll be doing a reaction review for
that instantaneously I cannot wait ah
well thank you guys to say it sir to me
because I yeah I guess at the beginning
of this video at first I was like I
don't know if I want to check this out
because I kind of just want to
experience the trailer ahead but when I
heard November I was like good I kind of
want to know what's in it I kinda want
to spoil it for myself a little bit but
something I normally don't like doing
but I said screw it let's go for this
one
anyway guys thanks for saying that's my
way I'm excited to see Avengers infinity
war so I'm curious I got a couple
questions if you only saw the
description of this what part of it is
the
exciting for you and if you were at the
d23 Expo what part of it got the biggest
reaction from you all right leave your
comments down below thank you for tuning
in subscribe to the reel rejects click
that notification though follow me at
the Greg Alva on Instagram and Twitter
and you can check out our exclusive
perks and rewards over at patreon all
proceeds go to helping this channel run
much love to all of you